yeah hello and welcome to this video
playing pro low and see what we get
ready the crumbling c6 why can play two
different setups can play before based
okay so this is now clean out of the
window s equals B 5 we can play with d3
so I'm going to play with d3 I guess
okay what I like to do is use the long
diagonal this one fit a 1 2 h8 nice wood
Buick c1 and get look-see to tween a 1
this kind of thing I'll try it's also a
way to double on the C file quickly so
he expands you have to do this
I can look FC one next this is a
probably roughly equal position don't
think there's so much going on I mean I
have to admit that I'd rather be white
him but it's not a big big deal bit of a
mysterious move I mean black is slightly
limited in some way you cannot easily
move the bishop or night but is that a
big deal probably not yeah this is a
mistake because now we cannot take but i
don't know if that i will see if this
hurt someone you have to move the Queen
now and still he cannot take it of
course I can take and play Bishop 35
yeah me being too brooke has to take now
queen d 7 s Tony move and now let's take
and go on I have three it's probably
still equal i can go 94 that defies
those those kind of things a doubling I
mean at the end of everything I might
have to ship c7 so he cannot so easily
trade down everything okay so it looks
you wanna stay idea and that's an
interesting colors covers it covers
everything c7 lost
trifa we should be six
but if i take now who does it cover
everything Queen takes Queen decks
Bishop takes we should be six and I win
8 5 and if the bishop takes I have Queen
to see 5 all night all 95 and also is
interesting right e5 queen d 7 has to be
played if i just take right i can just
take actually this is not bad night
takes and then Quincy five okay so so
prevents 95 and on Quincy five I have to
yeah to reckon with Quincy seven ok this
is trying to play night the five but
that wins a five-run
that wins 85 no okay black reason nor
the second threat I defended this quite
well I mean it looked like white was a
bit better but not sure that there was
anything substantial this yeah I'm
anything substantial so here the engine
gives black a slight edge I don't really
believe black can be better almost ever
but okay it's it's it's equal i guess
this all very normal bit mysterious
rupee aid and after this i'm getting a
bit of an initiative or the engine
actually finds something it finds efore
here interesting move what is that the
idea d takes from the nite nite c4 no
this one I because it's a direct pin and
I'm threatening this Andy fives okay so
there were some ideas down i played this
move which is scenes which leads to
nothing hey this also makes some sense
but it keeps it covered and here i don't
have anything it seems interesting
so that was the mistake yeah but should
be six I thought about this but Oh at
the good good example for stopping to
earlier I was just seeing a code bishops
III and well he still cannot cover five
I mean I can do whatever and take it
next now I just stopped too early so
that was good yeah and here the gtex was
good yeah this is very good for white
after 25 or 95 you can see fire water
should be good 95 seems to even better
but this is a good movie ajit eggs and
now I've got very very little only now
I'm winning i guess the a five point is
just too big to lose and gain the end of
the bush or even yeah a close one you be
defended well for the most part ok guys
thanks for watching